[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
massiven guten abend an diesem mittwoch
die sportlichen nachrichten heute wieder
mit norbert lammert genannt und dann
schauen wir gemeinsam auf einige unserer
themen
russlands angriffe gehen weiter erneut
sterben menschen beim beschuss mehrerer
städte in der ukraine
gleichzeitig sind beide seiten weiter im
gespräch
wieder ein starkes erdbeben in japan
teile tokios sind ohne strom die
erdstöße mit der stärke 7 3 erschüttern
auch die region um die atomruine
fukushima
und die zahl der korona infektionen
steigt weiter die geplanten eröffnungen
sorgen auch in der koalition für
diskussionen
es bleibt dabei russlands präsident
putin lebt in seiner eigenen realität
und wirft dem westen vor russland mit
den sanktionen zerstören zu wollen und
russische staatsbürger zu diskriminieren
widersprüchlich auch was russlands
außenminister und ukraine präsident
sehen nämlich fortschritte bei ihren
verhandlungen während gleichzeitig
weiterhin bomben fallen und menschen
sterben luton lynas und sarah laska in
kiew ist es der erwartet gefährliche
morgen hohe wohnhäuser das ziel der
russischen raketen angriffe als diese
vorbei sind wagen sich die
rettungskräfte nach draußen um
verschüttete aus den gebäuden zu holen
die 4 verfügte ausgangssperre gilt
weiter bis morgen früh 7 uhr
für larissa war es eine furchtbare nacht
als wir sie erreichen wieder luftalarm
sie will trotzdem berichten
haben viele explosionen gehört in kiew
mehr als in den tagen vorher die größte
angst haben wir vor raketen denn die
sind völlig unberechenbar
in dieser leihmutter klinik in kiew sind
20 babys von ihren eltern abgeschnitten
denn die meisten kommen wegen des
krieges nicht ins land
dieses paar aus deutschland hat für
seinen sohn die gefährliche reise gewagt
es ist schrecklich einfach nur
schrecklich wir holen ihn nach hause
damit er bei uns ist und in sicherheit
tag 21 dieses krieges gekennzeichnet von
geringen russischen geländegewinnen und
weiterhin heftigen kämpfe um strategisch
wichtige städte so liegt die stadtkerne
550 kilometer nördlich von kiew weiter
unter heftigen beschuss und libro
bereiten freiwillige die verteidigung
ihrer stadt vor die vor wenigen tagen
schwere luftangriffe erlebte hart
umkämpft ist auch der südosten der
ukraine insbesondere die belagerten
städte wollen wacher und mario pohl
aus dem von jeder versorgung
abgeschnittenen mario pohl heute nur
diese bilder einer völlig zerstörten
schule
gestern gelang fast 30.000 einwohnern
mario bulls in diesem konvoi die flucht
ein weiterer konvoi heute wurde nach
ukrainischen angaben mit raketen
angegriffen
präsident selensky bat heute vor dem
us-kongress um hilfe und forderte
us-präsident beiden auf anführer der
welt zu sein
anführer der welt bedeutet anführer des
friedens zu sein
gestern abend hatte sie lenski wie
regierungschefs von polen tschechien und
slowenien in kiew empfangen der
polnische vize regierungschef kaczynski
sprach sich dabei für eine
friedensmission der nato in der ukraine
aus
der internationale gerichtshof hat heute
angeordnet russland muss den krieg
sofort einstellen es ist jetzt nicht
davon auszugehen dass das passiert aber
beide seiten verhandeln zumindest über
eine waffenruhe und da fragen wir jetzt
katrin eigendorf in odessa wie ist das
denn einzuschätzen
ja wie wir aus der ukrainischen
verhandlungsdelegation hören ist man
wohl einem treffen zwischen beiden
präsidenten also zwischen putin und
selen ski einen schritt näher gekommen
grundlage dieses treffens sollen 15
punkte plan sein an dem die beiden
delegationen noch arbeiten also einen
konkreten termin gibt es nicht aber
immerhin eine perspektive und das ist
natürlich ein weiter schritt aber viele
menschen sehen dass hier sehr kritisch
denn gerade heute abend kommt die
meldung dass die russen in mario pool
ein theater bombardiert haben dass ein
schutzkeller für hunderte von menschen
waren also hunderte von zivilisten
wurden dort getroffen das lässt
natürlich die perspektive für wirklich
eine annäherung nicht wachsen danke
schön in die süd ukraine nach odessa
katrin eigendorf
in brüssel muss man dieser tage einen
ganz schönen diplomatie slalom hinlegen
gestern erst der mehr oder weniger
abgestimmte hochriskante trip
osteuropäischer regierungschefs nach
kiew heute wurde der polnische vorschlag
für eine nato friedensmission in der
ukraine bekannt was die nato aber
ablehnt heute trafen sich ihre
verteidigungsminister in brüssel dazu
eine klinik
es ist eine neue eine wiedererstarkte
nato in der sich die 30 verteidigungs
minister und ministerinnen bei ihrem
treffen in brüssel wieder finden hinter
verschlossenen türen wird der
ukrainische ressortchef per video
zugeschaltet um über die aktuelle lage
in seinem land zu berichten die nato
versucht die ukraine nach kräften zu
unterstützen ohne zugleich kriegspartei
zu werden
die nato alliierten sind sich einig
darin dass die nato weder truppen am
boden noch luftstreitkräfte über der
ukraine einsetzen wird denn wir tragen
verantwortung dafür dass dieser krieg
sich nichts über die ukraine hinaus
ausbreitet
um russland abzuschrecken haben nato
staaten zusätzliche truppen ins baltikum
nach polen in die slowakei und nach
rumänien verlegt insgesamt sind jetzt
100.000 us soldaten in europa
stationiert plus 40.000 in multi
nationalen verbänden unter nato kommando
unterdessen ist der krieg in der ukraine
am wochenende näher an die allianz
herangerückt russische raketen
zerstörten diese nato übungs basis
unweit der ukrainisch polnischen grenze
auch waffenlieferungen einzelner
mitgliedstaaten hat russland als ziele
ausgemacht die verteidigungsminister
aber bleiben dabei die nato lasse sich
nicht provozieren
auch wenn es bisher keine anhaltspunkte
dafür gibt dass das bündnisgebiet
angegriffen wird so können wir das nicht
gänzlich ausschließen und wir müssen
vorbereitet sein vorbereitet sein heißt
mehr gemeinsame übungen mehr truppen
mehr geld aus den mitgliedstaaten die
nato auf der suche nach dem richtigen
weg um die ukraine zu unterstützen und
sich dennoch in keinen neuen krieg
hineinziehen zu lassen
weiterhin fliehen jeden tag tausende
verzweifelte menschen aus der ukraine
laut bundesinnenministerium suchen
mittlerweile rund
175.000 flüchtende schutz in deutschland
die tatsächliche zahl dürfte wohl höher
sein die meisten kommen in berlin an
etwa 10.000 und das täglich in bayern
wurden seit kriegsbeginn insgesamt mehr
als 55.000 ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
erfasst mehr von david guetta hat sie
sind in sicherheit doch der krieg in
ihrer heimat halt nach
ich wache manchmal plötzlich aus dem
schlaf auf und höre explosionen
sie wollen finanzielle erst hilfen
beantragen doch vor dem amt für wohnen
und migration in münchen geht es nach
hunderten kilometern flucht heute nur
zentimeterweise voran
ich höre dass leute seit gestern hier
stehen also ich weiß nicht ob wir heute
noch ankommen die flüchtlingszahlen
steigen haben die behörden hat die
innenministerin die lage im griff heute
schwerpunkt der regierungsbefragung die
cdu wirft dem bund bei der registrierung
versäumnisse vor feser wehrt sich
das bmz unterstützt die länder dabei mit
registriert stationen das werden wir
weiter intensivieren die registrierung
erfolgt spätestens wenn menschen
unterstützungsleistungen in der
bundesrepublik brauchen es seien vor
allem frauen und kinder geflüchtete aus
der ukraine müssen kein asyl beantragen
genießen visafreiheit die afg setzt
darauf geflüchtete gegeneinander
auszuspielen
wir wollen nicht die selbe kontroll
verweigerung wie 20 15 sonst bleibt
deutschland wieder sperrangelweit offen
für alle arten unerwünschter
trittbrettfahrer die meisten
allermeisten menschen reisen mit
biometrischen pass visafreien unser land
ein die die sie angesprochen haben sind
sechs prozent der einreisenden und ich
hatte es auch eingangs gesagt
bundespolizei registriert dort und
deswegen gibt es auch keinen grund das
so aufzubauschen nun geht es vor allem
darum die geflüchteten gerecht auf alle
16 länder zu verteilen die wollen geld
vom bund etliche bundesländer sind nicht
in der lage das finanziell zu schultern
deswegen brauchen wir auch morgen bei
der minister ist ein ganz klares signal
nicht nur dass die länder dies fordern
besonders der bundes auch macht und
übernimmt die unterstützung der
geflüchteten trägt derzeit vor allem
eine zivilgesellschaftliche handschrift
die politik muss nachziehen und hat viel
vor
und wenn sie den menschen helfen wollen
können sie das über das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine und mehr
infos auf spenden zdf.de oder auf der
zdf textseite 890
morgen wird die ampel regierung 100 tage
im amt seien von anfang an krisenmodus
und mehrfach von der realität eingeholt
opfern corona oder vom krieg und das hat
auswirkungen auf den bundeshalt
bundeshaushalt 2022 den das kabinett
heute verabschiedet hat und 100
milliarden euro soll die neuverschuldung
betragen nicht miteingerechnet weitere
100 milliarden euro durch den ukraine
krieg mehr details hat karl
hinterleitner
seit den ersten haushaltsentwurf hatte
sich christian lindner wahrscheinlich
anders vorgestellt denn eigentlich
wollte der neue finanzminister zurück
richtung schwarze null aber in diesen
zeiten wird daraus nichts diese
haushalts
wäre jetzt wechsel ich in den konjunktiv
wäre ein schritt zur normalisierung der
haushaltspolitik dieses landes nach zwei
an demi haushalten gewesen was lindner
meint nach jahren der schwarzen null und
der höchsten neuverschuldung der
geschichte 2021 plante man für dieses
jahr einen rückgang auf unter 100
milliarden euro doch dazu soll jetzt ein
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr kommen
mit weiteren 100 milliarden ablehnung
von der opposition
nun soll die bevölkerung dieses
wettrüsten einfach so akzeptieren ich
kann ganz deutlich sagen für uns als
linke wir werden diesen kriegskredite
nicht zustimmen und die union kritisiert
das ausmaß der kreditaufnahme oder
war zeitenwende aktuell sprechen dann
wird das auch für die haushaltspolitik
wir werden wieder schulden haushalte
erleben im finanzplanungszeitraum kommen
wir kein jahr ohne neue schulden auf die
schuldenbremse 2023 da mache ich viele
fragezeichen dran dabei kommt die
gesamtrechnung ist noch einen ergänzungs
haushalt soll folgekosten des ukraine
kriegs wie explodierender energiepreise
abfedern höhe zurzeit unbekannt auf
christian lindners haushalt 22 könnten
schon in den nächsten wochen einige
milliarden schulden obendrauf kommen
ja gerade noch gehört es kommt auf jeden
fall noch eine ergänzungs haushalt darin
enthalten zuschüsse für autofahrer und
haushalte mit geringem einkommen wegen
der hohen energiepreise so hat das
kabinett heute beschlossen die
pendlerpauschale soll zum beispiel in
diesem jahr angehoben werden und bis
2026 gelten der bereits angekündigte
heizkosten zuschlag für
einkommensschwache haushalte wird
verdoppelt und es gibt einen sofort
zuschlag für ärmere familien
in japan hat ein beben den nordosten des
landes erschüttert die stärke wird mit
7,3 angegeben das epizentrum im meer lag
nahe des vor elf jahren havarierten
atomkraftwerkes fukushima bilder aus der
40 kilometer weiter südlich gelegenen
stadt iwaki zeigen lichtblitze die nach
kurzschlüssen die nacht erhellen in 200
kilometer entfernten tokio bebte die
erde ebenfalls minuten lang zwei
millionen menschen waren vorübergehend
ohne strom die behörden gaben eine
tsunami warnung heraus wir sprechen mit
ulf röller ist unser asien korrespondent
und wie schätzen sie die aktuelle lage
ein
also das beben ist jetzt etwa drei
stunden her und deswegen kann man glaube
ich ganz vorsichtig sagen dass japan
glück im unglück gehabt hat das hat
gewaltiges erdbeben gegeben aber die
ganz ganz große katastrophe die vor elf
jahren eben die welt und japan so tief
erschüttert hat die bleibt wohl aus es
gibt eine zunahme wird tsunami welle die
ist etwa ein meter hoch das letzte mal
vor elf jahren war sie bis zu 16 meter
hoch da kann man den unterschied sehen
zwei millionen menschen sind ohne strom
neun präfekturen sind davon betroffen
und viel infrastruktur und auch einige
verletzte soll es geben die japanische
regierung hat gerade eine
pressekonferenz gemacht und hat gesagt
sie glaubt dass sie die lage im griff
hat und sie glaubt auch dass die
atomkraftwerke einigermaßen sicher so
unbeschädigt sind also wie gesagt fazit
vorläufig glück im unglück danke ulf
röller wir kommen jetzt zur pandemie und
den steigenden zahlen die belasten auch
die krankenhäuser nach angaben der
deutschen krankenhausgesellschaft wurden
wieder mehr mit corona infizierte
patienten eingeliefert gleichzeitig
fällt personal aus dass in quarantäne
ist laut lka gab es 262
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden 46
1739 mehr als vor einer woche 269
todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben tage
incidents hat einen neuen höchstwert
erreicht und liegt nun bei 1600 7,1
kroner höchstwerte im bundestag ging es
heute um die änderungen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
ab kommenden sonntag sollen die korona
maßnahmen jahr reduziert werden trotz
steigender zahl über debatte und
kontroversen heike slansky
einer fehlte auf der regierungsbank der
bundesgesundheitsministerium dessen
gesetzes heute gehen soll die union
verlangt seiner anwesenheit deswegen
fordern wir die zitierung des ministers
kabinettsklausur zeitgleich so die
begründung zehn minuten später ist karl
lauterbach da reden lässt der andere mit
dem 19 märz enden die aktuellen co oder
maßnahmen das bedeutet wir müssen als
gesetzgeber tätig werden und wir mussten
eine einigung erzielen ab sonntag soll
nur noch einen basisschutz gelten per
anordnung darunter masken pflicht in
altenheimen und krankenhäusern im
öffentlichen nah und fernverkehr
testpflicht auch in schulen und kitas
ein kompromiss der auf druck der fdp
zustande kam und der uns grüne nicht
zufriedenstellt aber er ist das was
unter demokratischen bedingungen in der
ampel miteinander verabredet werden
kommt trotz höchstständen bei den
infektions und todeszahlen verteidigt
die fdp ihren kurs hier sind nicht in
derselben situation wie vor zwei jahren
wir haben wirksame impfstoffe meine
damen und herren auch gegen omikron
deswegen fordere ich immer lassen sie
sich impfen und lassen sie sich gut dann
mit hotspot regelungen sollen die
landesparlamente künftig selbst
entscheiden ob sie eine weitergehende
masken pflicht hygiene konzepte 2 oder 3
g anordnen wollen den meisten reicht das
nicht
ganz grundsätzlich müssen die länder vor
allen dingen auch beispielsweise die
möglichkeiten haben
zugangsbeschränkungen zu verhängen in
zugespitzten situation
ein hoch umstrittenes gesetz das auf den
letzten drücker in dieser woche
durchgepeitscht werden soll
dann machen wir sportlich weiter
fußball-champions-league es gab zwei
spannende achtelfinal rückspiele und das
sind zwei große vereine rausgeflogen
ajax amsterdam scheitert überraschend an
benfica lissabon und manchester united
an atlético madrid das spanische abwehr
bollwerk konnte selbst superstar
cristiano ronaldo nicht knacken selbst
die besten möglichkeiten waren nicht gut
genug für manchester und auch nicht die
fußballerische genialität eines
cristiano ronaldo kein guter abend damit
auch für trainer ralf rangnick und den
spiegel seiner stresshormone schon in
der ersten halbzeit hätte united dem
spiel einen anderen verlauf geben können
wenn nicht torhüter ob lachs kopf
atlético madrid den hals gerettet hätte
dreizehnte minute und so kam es dass
kurz vor der pause die spanier die
entscheidende lücke in der englischen
abwehr fanden 1 0 durch den brasilianer
renaldo die mensch ist dass trainer
rangnick kann und muss nun alle kräfte
bündeln für die premier league ziel ist
der vierte platz und damit die
qualifikation für die champions league
ob er die aber noch als trainer erlebt
ist fraglich
und heute abend dann noch die beiden
partien turin gegen villarreal und lehre
gegen chelsea alle tore und highlights
der vier achtelfinal- rückspiel bei uns
zu sehen in sportstudio champions league
um 23 uhr bei den paralympics in peking
waren sie das zweitbeste team jetzt ist
die ukrainische mannschaft zurück in
europa das team landete gestern abend in
warschau wurde dort begeistert empfangen
der großteil der mannschaft will jetzt
trotz des krieges über land weg zurück
in die ukraine mehrere europäische
staaten haben den sportlerinnen und
sportler aber auch eine neue heimat und
unterstützung angeboten
der deutsche fußball trauert um egidius
braun werfer starb heute im alter von 97
jahren
von 1992 bis 2001 war dfb präsident und
hatte sich vor allem für die vergabe der
fußball wm 2006 nach deutschland stark
gemacht in seine zeit fiel auch der
deutsche em titel 1996 die soziale
verantwortung des sports war dem
ehrenpräsidenten immer wichtig eine dfb
stiftung trägt seinen namen
fußball ist mehr als ein 1 0 und das war
sein motto dankeschön norbert und von
fußball weisheiten zum schon gestern
angekündigten saharastaub davon hatten
selbst die hamburger reichlich jede
menge staub plus tonne ergibt
romantische morgen impressionen und noch
wüsten artiger saß in spanien aus die
costa brava komplett orange sie glauben
wir hätten einen farbfilter draufgelegt
haben wir nicht hier der beweis
vom farbenspiel jetzt zum zahlenspiel
hier sind die zahlen vom mittwochslotto
und die gehen so
168 16 19 40 und die superzahl 0
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf.de
und auf der zdf textseite 557 gleich das
wetter mit rtl ii so viel vorweg
bisschen regen weniger sonne das heute
journal mit marietta slomka wie gewohnt
um 21 uhr 45 vielen dank fürs zuschauen
das gesamte heute 19 team wünscht noch
einen entspannten abend und bis mo
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter diese zwei hochs
werden sich zum wochenende verbinden zu
einem sehr umfangreichen hoch mit 1050
hektopascal
da gibt es viel sonnenschein war vorher
gibt es morgen diese kaltfront hier und
die bringt bereits in der nacht ganz im
westen regen ansonsten klart es vor
allem im osten auf und ausbau tiefsten
temperaturen dort von null bis minus 2
grad hier leichter frost und 9 grad am
niederrhein morgen dann am vormittag im
westen erster regen und er setzt sich
dann allmählich in die mitte und nach
osten hin durch dahinter lockert es
schon wieder auf und die sonne kommt
hervor bei höchsten temperaturen im
westen bei 8 bis 13 grad hier also eine
deutlich kältere luftmasse als im osten
und im südwesten dort bis 18 grad die
kommenden tage sehr sonnig freitag noch
im osten dichter bewölkt bei acht bis 15
grad und samstag und am sonntag
temperaturen bei acht bis vierzehn ein
schöner abend